hang on to something
we just got a little ray of sunshine or
should I say lightning because it was
just announced at a Percy Jackson TV
series is in the work so we're gonna
break down what we might see in that
right now on the catch up Percy Jackson
and the Olympians about the adventures
of young demigod Percy has been one of
the most popular children's literature
series over the past 15 years and now
it's becoming a TV series on Disney Plus
where it could become another tentpole
to go alongside shows like the
mandalorian and perhaps the upcoming
Marvel series now the author of the
books Rick Riordan along with his wife
Becky made the big announcement on
Twitter recently by making this really
cute video Percy Jackson is coming to
Disney Plus yes yes and also with a
longer statement from Rick so in it he
says they're excited about a live-action
series of the highest quality adding
that it will follow the storyline of the
original five book series starting with
the lightning thief in season one which
is the first book but as you may
remember this same idea happened back in
2010 but in movie form when the rotten
Percy Jackson and the Olympians the
lightning thief starring Logan Lerman
hit theaters it got decent box office
numbers but ultimately rub fans the
wrong way
I used to date your daddy that was
followed up by 2013 Percy Jackson sea of
monsters also rotten with fans once
again not feeling it largely due to
deviations from the source material so
basically plans for a third film were
scrapped after that that was awesome but
this time around
Rick's seemingly tried to put fans at
ease by suggesting that this adaptation
will be closer to the books saying rest
assured that Becky and I will be
involved in person in every aspect of
the show and that seemed to work because
fans on Twitter are absolutely stoked
for this after waiting so many years so
thank you uncle Rick now if the series
does follow the books more closely we
should expect to see a young Percy
discovering his demigod status and
figuring out his powers in the first
season and he could be joined by other
characters like Grover Underwood who in
the books is a forest spirit with a
human torso and Annabeth chase a
daughter of Athena so in the book those
to join with Percy to help him clear as
a master Zhu Zhu Hughes's Percy of
stealing his master lightning bolts oh
the demigod drama I swear I don't know
how that got there it's not even my
shield now it is reportedly in the early
stages of development but if it does
turn out to be a hit for Disney Plus and
sticks to doing one book per season they
could also pull from the demigod files
and the demigod Eyre ease for more
series material or for potential
spin-offs I guess it's up to you the
fans speaking of which it is time for us
to kick it over to you guys now are you
excited for a Percy Jackson TV series
and if so who would you like to see cast
be sure to leave all your thoughts and
feelings in the comment section and for
more streaming news be sure to check out
Ryan Tomatoes calm also don't forget to
join our finger bump Facebook because
fans really matter to us like this one
what's up everyone my name is mylène
Garcia and I am in Riverside California
I hope you guys are all staying safe and
staying fresh and if you do not want to
miss out on any future episodes of this
show be sure to hit that subscribe
button and notification valve so you
don't miss out on any of the fun and as
always thank you so much for watching
the catch up my name
and we hope to see your face in the next
video
[Music]